[Music]
education and food go hand in hand and
at one school in a drought-stricken
region of tanzania one garden program
has changed a generation of school kids
[Music]
oh
[Music]
my name is safiyohana i'm teaching urban
school for the maasai and i formed the
gardening club one two three gardening
club before we started this gardening
club program we had so many students who
are absent because of hunger
the o'brien school has around 360
students the majority of whom are from
the maasai tribe an originally nomadic
group of people whose diets
traditionally consist of meat milk blood
and fat farming and eating vegetables
was not a part of their lifestyle but in
an area marked by extreme levels of
poverty and food scarcity kids were
malnourished and their education was
suffering
a lot of schools don't serve any food my
name is perry huggins and i am school
director here at o'brien school for the
mass eye
[Music]
to pay attention in class you need to
have a full stomach if you're thinking
about how hungry you are
how can you think about what you're
supposed to be learning
so the o'brien school did two things
they started a garden and began offering
two meals a day using the vegetables
they grew at the beginning when we
cooked vegetables they said did ya what
did they say that that those one are the
vegetables so they taste teacher
some are good
but after some few days they said
teacher it is nice
students growing and eating vegetables
is really a big deal in a masai
community
it's still very much lacking at home
so
emphasizing this at school is the only
place where they're learning hey eat
your vegetables
the school garden grows everything from
kale to cabbage tomatoes peppers okra
sweet potatoes and each day the students
are responsible for planting tending and
harvesting the crops everyone sees the
seeds
so we use the seeds as a medicine we
have very big changes
according to our garden there is changes
in academic the students have energy
their body it is health
[Music]
and these changes are not confined to
the classroom students have taken what
they've learned at school and brought it
home planting gardens with their
families in their local villages which
is all to say that the program is
working
there are definitely a lot of issues
that keep students away from school
but students being well fed is a very
good foundation for them being in school
[Music]
you